bonjour à tous bonne année 2023 là à
l'heure actuelle le second trailer
d'antania vient de sortir et sincèrement
ça promet on est très loin de la vibe du
premier trailer nous sommes face à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus sombre
qui révèle d'ailleurs beaucoup de choses
sur le film et franchement bah moi ça me
hype quand le Conquérant est bien Dark
et violent comme il faut et surtout je
peux pas m'empêcher de me dire que si
ils nous ont dévoilé tout ça dans le
trailer et bien cela veut dire que le
film peut potentiellement cacher des
secrets encore plus grands ça y est nous
rentrons définitivement dans la phase 5
vous connaissez la coutume qui dit
nouveau trailer dit analyse et théorie
du coup bah voyons ensemble ce que nous
pouvons en tirer allez c'est parti
premièrement ce second trailer confirme
certaines théories et autres
informations Janet van Ding connaît donc
véritablement Kang le Conquérant comme
supposé elle servira d'après moi de
points de bascule pour le spectateur car
bien évidemment est un grand
manipulateur il semble se présenter sous
son meilleur jour devant Scott mais
voilà vous le savez tous c'est un très
grand vilain et Janet le sait Janet est
celle qui sera nous ramener les pieds
sur terre concernant Kong nous rappeler
à quel point il est dangereux mais
surtout cela peut sous-entendre qu'elle
sera aussi l'une des clés du film pour
contrer l'antagoniste soit proche de tes
ennemis autant que de tes amis d'un
autre côté nous avons enfin eu un
premier aperçu de modoch et pas des
moindres il semblerait bien que nous
soyons face au retour de Yellow Jake le
vilain du premier film Ant-Man c'est un
choix intéressant car au vu du passif
entre Yello jacket et Ant-Man cela
rajoute du poids dans la balance de
l'histoire car les deux personnages sont
de véritables ennemis pour rappel Yello
jacket avait été envoyé dans le champ
quantique lors de sa bataille contre
Scotland dans le premier film et au vu
de ce qu'il y a dans le trailer cela
confirme potentiellement une théorie que
je vous avais proposée c'est que Kang
soit le créateur de mode doc pour la
faire courte Modock est à la base un
humain qui a été transformé par des
scientifiques d'une organisation très
secrète centrée sur la technologie pour
devenir un super ordinateur vivant comme
je vous l'avais supposé bah Kang est un
brillant scientifique qui manipule les
technologies du futur envoyant moque aux
côtés de Kang qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
accompagné par les bottes de Kang
contrairement à Cassis et bien cela veut
dire que les personnages sont de mèches
yellow Jake en atterrissant dans le
champ quantique aurait été recueilli par
Kang le conquérant et c'est comme ça
qu'il serait devenu le super ordinateur
vivant mais maintenant intéressons-nous
à la trame principale car je trouve que
les trailers est beaucoup plus profond
que l'on pourrait le penser en fait
plusieurs questions surgissent quand on
voit les deux trailers pourquoi Kang a
besoin d'antan
va chercher pour quand le conquérant et
du coup bah si modoch est également de
la partie cela veut dire que lui aussi a
son impact et son importance mais du
coup quel est-il tout d'abord ce que je
trouve très pertinent c'est que Kang se
sert justement du fait kantman est
disparu pendant 5 ans à cause du snap de
Thanos et accessoirement le fait qu'il
est toujours eu des problèmes avec la
justice l'empêchant de profiter de sa
famille pour souligner le temps qu'il a
perdu avec Cassie et comme dévoilé par
Janet Kang est capable de réécrire
l'existence et disloquer des flux
temporelles ceci est une caractéristique
propre du personnage car Kang au niveau
du temps contrairement à Immortus qui
dans le MCU et celui qui demeure et bien
c'est l'incarnation du chaos Kang
n'hésite pas à parcourir les époques
conquérir les flux temporelles et
modifier le temps à sa guise peu importe
ce qui en découle derrière Scotland a
perdu beaucoup de temps mais là où c'est
intrig que Kang nous affirme que lui
aussi et c'est là que c'est intéressant
car comme dévoilé dans le trailer Kang a
besoin d'anthman pour trouver du temps
et une fois ça acquis il pourra en faire
profiter Scotland aussi avec cassis mais
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire exactement
trouver du temps personnellement j'ai
deux interprétations concernant ceci et
cela pourrait expliquer comment quand
pourrait débloquer la suite concernant
Avengers de candynastie et Secret Wars
pour moi Kang est à la recherche soit
d'un artefact soit d'un endroit et du
coup modoch étant une intelligence
supérieure un super ordinateur vivant
etc et bien il l'est dans localisant ce
qu'il souhaite premier cas de figure
Kang est à la recherche de la sphère de
lumière liée au temps dans les comics
pour faire bref c'est une sphère donc
Kang se sert pour voyager et faire
voyager des gens à travers
se passe et le temps c'est un objet lui
permettant d'accéder à n'importe quel
moment du temps de manière simple et
rapide cela concorderait avec l'idée que
Kang est bloquée dans le champ quantique
l'objet étant potentiellement
inaccessible car dans une partie trop
petite du champ quantique et bien
Ant-Man seulement lui pour elle le
récupérer néanmoins j'aimais une réserve
car comme dévoilé par Janet nous sommes
face à un Kang le conquérant qui est
quand même déjà bien établi il est déjà
capable de réécrire l'existence il est
déjà capable de causer des dégâts aux
flux temporels il a déjà du vécu il sait
qui est Ant-Man si non il ne lui ferait
pas miroiter de rattraper le temps perdu
avec Cassie bref nous sommes face à un
Kang qui connaît son sujet et qui
semblerait voyage déjà beaucoup dans le
temps d'ailleurs dans le premier trailer
nous le voyons utiliser une sphère
depuis sa base de chronopolis du coup il
se pourrait qu'il est déjà cette sphère
pour effectuer ses voyages mais voilà ce
ne sont que des suppositions et second
cas de figure celui qui m'attire le plus
mais voilà je rappelle qu'on est dans de
la théorie c'est que Kang soit à la
recherche d'un endroit et plus
particulièrement une certaine dimension
en fait comme Kang le dit lui-même dans
le premier trailer cette dimension n'est
pas celle que l'on croit il peut parler
d'une dimension précise ou bien du champ
quantique lui-même mais dans les deux
cas en fait c'est cohérent c'est un
sujet que j'aimerais développer dans une
prochaine vidéo mais le concept de
dimension est très important et ce même
dans l'histoire de Kang dans les comics
pour faire simple dites-vous que les
dimensions se sont des morceaux
d'univers à coller du coup les unes aux
autres vous avez l'exemple avec Talo
dans le shankshi ou bien tout simplement
le chant quantique ce sont des endroits
de la terre qui sont accolés à cette
dernière et c'est pourquoi nous pouvons
voyager dedans sauf que c'est là que
c'est intéressant car la base ces
dimensions permettent justement accès à
d'autres dimensions et c'est le cas
notamment du chant quantique on en avait
parlé dans une précédente vidéo mais le
chant quantique est déjà rien qu'elle
une dimension très particulière là-bas
nous avons en fait plusieurs étages ou
plutôt plusieurs secteurs nous avons des
univers dans cette dimension et c'est
pourquoi elle est aussi grande et c'est
certainement aussi pourquoi quand s'est
installé là-bas mais surtout comme la
démontrer endgame c'est un endroit relié
au temps nous pouvons voyager dans le
temps grâce aux chants quantique car il
y a plusieurs conduites temporelles et
autres vortex et c'est là que je
m'interroge est-ce que Kang dans le
champ quantique ne serait pas à la
recherche d'un endroit d'une dimension
où le temps serait nul car déjà de 1 bah
ils ne vieillit jamais comme ça comme
dans les comics et surtout en fait où il
aurait une emprise totale sur toute la
temporalité voyez ça genre un endroit
comme un point qui permettrait de donner
accès à tout n'importe où bref un
endroit où il pourrait véritablement
commencer sa dynastie pour à terme du
coup bah nous donner les films Avengers
si je vous dis ça ce n'est pas par
hasard car dans les comics Kang est plus
particulièrement son futur lui-même
Immortus se serre notamment de la
dimension des limbes qui est un point
central du multivers pour interagir
partout que ce soit dans le temps ou
dans l'espace si on relativise c'est ce
que fait déjà celui qui demeure il a
atteint ce point et pour moi c'est la
prochaine étape pour Kang depuis le
chant quantique il a appréhendé le
voyage dans le temps il peut créer des
Nexus modifier les time line etc tout ça
cela semble déjà acquis mais dans sa
quête l'étape supérieure bah c'est le
multivers lui-même et gérer la menace
des autres Kangs variants et autres
éléments qui me fait appuyer cette idée
c'est que dans le trailer nous voyons
que Kang est capable de se déplacer
partout dans le champ quantique il est
capable découvrir des portes entre
guillemets vers d'autres dimensions il a
déjà conquis plusieurs royaumes dans les
comics d'ailleurs et ce qui me fait un
petit quai c'est qu'il y a un portail
qui semble très important dans le
trailer nous voyons cassis doté devant
Scott se bat avec Kang devant le même
portail comme si il voulait l'empêcher
de le prendre et bizarrement on n'arrive
pas à voir de l'autre côté ce qu'il y a
peut-être que je m'emballe et qu'il
s'agisse simplement d'un portail pouvant
permettre à Kang d'arriver sur la terre
à notre époque bien que je pense qu'il
soit un peu tôt pour ça ou bien
peut-être qu'il peut s'agir d'un endroit
précis une dimension aussi Kang y accède
et bien il passe à l'étape supérieure et
sa dynastie se met véritablement en
place mais voilà tout ça ce ne sont que
des théories je peux avoir raison je
peux avoir tort je vous fais par
simplement de mes interprétations et de
comment je vois les choses dans tous les
cas je vais peut-être vous surprendre
mais je me demande aussi ce Kang ne va
pas mourir à la fin du film on le voit
dans un état pas possible face à Ant-Man
chronopolis semble tomber en ruine et
Kang semble en être complètement enragé
en fait Marvel peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent avec ce Kang car la
particularité du personnage comme nous
la précisé la série Loki d'ailleurs et
bien c'est qu'il en existe une infinité
à cause des voyages dans le temps etc tu
es un Kang bah un autre Kang reviendra
très vite je suis même excité à l'idée
de me dire que pourquoi pas à l'issue
dantman quantumania Scotland réussirait
à vaincre ce Kang car comme il le dit
toute façon il s'en fout de gagner du
moment que lui et Kang perdent et par
conséquent cela veut dire cantman a
finalement gagné du temps comme symbole
par rapport au pitch de base du film
mais voilà à terme il aura simplement
retardé l'inévitable et puis même je
garde à l'idée que ce Kang sert avant
tout d'introduction pour le personnage
nous en rencontrerons beaucoup d'autres
avec d'autres
identités mais à terme le Kang qui est
vraiment important c'est celui destiné à
devenir celui qui demeure et comme le
démontre leur physique et bien ce ne
sont pas les mêmes
[Musique]
enfin voilà je m'éparpille beaucoup je
suis désolé mais quand on parle de Kang
et bien j'ai toujours plein de choses à
dire en soit n'oubliez pas que ce sont
simplement des théories des
interprétations ça vient que de moi
Marvel actuellement est totalement libre
concernant Kang et c'est pourquoi le
sujet est aussi difficile le trailer a
beau être riche en visuel etc c'est très
difficile de deviner ce qu'ils vont
faire par la suite parce que ils peuvent
faire tout et n'importe quoi avec Kang
en soi moi je vous aimez simplement ce
que je pense logique ce que moi je ferai
d'après l'univers des comics etc mais le
MCU ce n'est pas les comics et avec le
concept de multivers de voyage j'entends
etc et bien Marvel voilà ils font ce
qu'ils veulent quoi en tout cas j'ai
très hâte de voir les réponses que nous
apportera le film je pense qu'il nous
cache du très lourd d'ailleurs
concernant les dimensions convoitées par
Kang je vous parlais justement des
limbes d'ailleurs apparaît dans Loki
c'est un point clé franchement dans
l'histoire du personnage mais on
pourrait également pourquoi pas amener
la zone négative qui est aussi une
dimension très importante et un peu
accolé à tout mais voilà tout ça on y
reviendra je vous avoue je vous prépare
pas mal de vidéos en ce moment
concernant The Kong dynastie et Secret
Wars et c'est vraiment un sujet
compliqué bref sur ce j'espère que ma
vidéo vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à me
faire vos impressions en commentaire ce
que vous pensez qu'il y aura dans le
film qu'est-ce que Kang recherche
exactement etc comment vous voyez les
choses vous en fait j'attends énormément
Ant-Man quand tout Mania j'ai vraiment
très hâte et voilà la phase 5 commence
enfin et ça fait ultra plaisir que le
lionhar soit avec vous allez c’était
argorock c'était une petite vidéo de
chill on va revenir sur ce sujet vous en
faites pas allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]